[Musica]
sono parte della generazione z è una
generazione che per quanto sia forte con
le connessioni virtuali non lo è così
tanto con quelle sociali è proprio
questo che mi ha portato ad avvicinarmi
alla fotografia è nato tutto come un
modo per riuscire a studiare le persone
che mi circondano per cercare di capire
da bambino
se le motivazioni che mi spingono ad
affrontare la vita quotidiana siano
quelle che spingono anche le altre
persone ad affrontare la loro poi si
cresce
era febbraio 2018 ho partecipato a
master o fotografi un programma
televisivo di sky arte e circondata da
tutti questi fotografi adulti affermati
professionisti
mi sono trovato a chiedermi ma starò
crescendo sarò all'altezza di questa
situazione effettivamente crescere ci
pone di fronte a possibilità infinita di
conoscere persone punti di vista
differenti ci pone di fronte a stimoli
ogni giorno anche troppi per cui il
motivo iniziale per cui fotografavo è
praticamente svanito posso conoscere le
persone anche senza l'obiettivo proprio
per questo motivo mi sono trovato
ultimamente a chiedermi perché continui
a fotografare perché continua a prendere
qualcuno da parte e guardarlo negli
occhi e guardando ancora e ancora e come
se ciò non bastasse dopo alcuni minuti
vestirlo posizionarlo dirigerlo quale
sarà la risposta fermo fermi tutti un po
più desta un po più a destra abbassa lo
sguardo sollevamento frontale fermo
ok guardami questa è una situazione
particolare ma è esattamente quello che
succede ogni volta che fotografo e che
cos'è allora che cerco in quello sguardo
quello che cerco è una situazione
specifica ma un po sfuggente ricorda in
qualche modo l'empatia e probabilmente
per la maggior parte di voi è una
sensazione scontata che si prova
quotidianamente ma quando sei timida e
cresce nella campagna non è così facile
trovarsi un paio di occhi da guardare e
un'occasione così rara che anche
quando si trovano questi occhi non è
facile guardarli e serve un filtro dalla
prima volta in cui è impregnato una
macchina fotografica ho capito di aver
trovato il mio filtro la mia porta sulle
persone e se c'è tra voi anche soltanto
una persona che non dà per scontata
questa sensazione che la deve ricercare
ogni giorno che si affatica
nell'avvicinarsi alle persone ecco io
parlo per quella persona d'altronde
passiamo la maggior parte del nostro
tempo in solitudine ed è naturale anzi
c'è qualcosa di speciale nel cercare il
nostro spazio di solitudine nella
fidarci soltanto i nostri sensi nel
concederci di avere un punto di vista
tutto nostro e approfittarne
d'altra parte da sempre la connessione
più forte è quella che ci lega alle
altre persone la fotografia è proprio un
modo per poterci ritrovare nelle persone
di fronte a noi è il mio modo per
riuscire a condividere quell'intimità e
ho scoperto che questa sensazione è
fortissima la fotografia assume un po
ruolo di una coperta di flanella quando
la sera siamo sul divano a coccolati e
sotto la coperta diventa immediatamente
naturale comportarsi in un modo che non
è naturale normalmente ci si avvicina ci
si accoccola ecco la fotografia rende
naturale guardarsi per più tempo di
quanto non sarebbe naturale farlo nella
vita quotidiana situazioni che
normalmente ci metterebbero a disagio
diventano perfettamente naturali ci
mettono a nostro agio
d'altra parte pensate una situazione di
silenzio di 4 minuti cinque minuti 6
minuti diventa pesante con l'obiettivo
invece diventa soltanto un'occasione per
chiedersi ma quindi anche tu sei un po
disagio forte
capita anche a me ma anche tu ti stai
sentendo un po solo ti capita a volte
cavolo allora siamo simili
ed è così che la fotografia diventa un
modo per sentirsi un po meno fuori luogo
un po parte di qualcosa
pensate a quella stranezza che
camminando tra la gente sembra così
gente è un po un gufo sulla spalla
sembra sempre che tutti ti stiano
guardando per quella cosa specifica ecco
nella fotografia invece diventa quello
che ci rende unici
quello che ci rende interessanti e
vederlo attraverso un obiettivo diventa
uno scambio di sensazioni
è una sensazione tonda piena che ti
avvolge e probabilmente è dovuto anche
al fatto che nella vita quotidiana
queste stranezze
cerchiamo di nasconderle cerchiamo di
tenerle per noi di limarle un pochino e
nella fotografia non è necessaria non è
necessario si diventa simili e ci si
rende conto che le incertezze e anche le
certezze non sono poi così unica le
provano anche le persone di fronte a noi
ma alla fine che cos'è che mi spinge a
mettere questa macchina fotografica
nello zaino
dopo la lezione di finanza e andare a
creare immagini che fino a quel momento
esistono soltanto nella mia mente
il motivo è uno solo è che questa
sensazione mi ha cambiato la vita e
credo che possa cambiarla a molte
persone
è una sensazione di sentirsi uniti e
sentirsi parte di una comunità
soltanto attraverso un paio di occhi il
tempo praticamente si prolunga e tutto
diventa più naturale ci troviamo
rispecchiati nella persona di fronte a
noi
d'altronde al giorno d'oggi basta
spegnere la sveglia e senza neanche
alzare il culo da letto
possiamo vedere il mondo attraverso
mille occhi diversi e il potere dei
social ma il potere dei social è anche
una volta bloccato il telefono
ritrovarci da soli di fronte alla
giornata che dobbiamo affrontare
ma la fotografia la fotografia quella
vera nasce per darci la possibilità di
confrontarci di studiarci di guardarci
negli occhi e rivederci nella persona di
fronte a noi ed è per questo che diventa
un'arma potentissima e della fotografia
ma potrebbe essere qualsiasi altro
linguaggio e il linguaggio più adatto a
ognuno di noi
la fotografia come ogni linguaggio ci
permette di comunicare in maniera molto
più intensa e diretta diventa una sorta
di arma diventa un'arma
perché perché nel silenzio viene facile
cercare di sdrammatizzare con una
battuta cercare di far pensare no io
sono forte
io sto bene ora ma in realtà attraverso
uno sguardo se soltanto lo lasciamo
parlare lo lasciamo evolvere lasciamo
che parli più chiaro delle parole allora
possiamo arrivare a capirci a capirci
davvero perché gli sguardi possono
parlare molto chiaro probabilmente più
chiaro di quanto non stia facendo io in
questi minuti e lo sguardo può
raccontarci che la solitudine può fare
male ma riuscire a stare soli insieme ea
godersi quella connessione silenziosa e
magia grazie
[Applauso]